[Applause]
wow
that's very cool
you ever get sick of it you get sick of
it it's nice wherever you go people go
crazy oh it's nice
it's nice out there i like that because
um i'm certainly one that's not really
comfortable with it
oh you're not you're not comfortable
with it i never have been can i have it
then is that okay
little the old adulation let's put it my
way uh
first of all thank you so much for being
here i touch on one area we're going to
start with because it just happened
which is
u.s loss to europe uh at the ryder cup
last weekend
tell us what happened what was your
analysis of of this seems to be a trend
what's going
on we got our ass kicked excellent we're
moving on now
now one thing no but one thing that i
did want to ask about was the the
spectators
are getting louder more raucous all the
time in in golf
do you think that we're headed to a
point i mean already it's changed so
much in 10 years i think you've helped
change this game a lot created a lot of
excitement for golf
where are we going 10 years from now air
horns zeppelins explosions
i mean do you think it's going to get
out of hand no i honestly believe it's
all tied into uh
consumption right of their favorite
beverage right
um ah that would be pepsi yeah
late um because late in the afternoon it
gets a little more ruckus than it is
middle of the day right
okay and and so are they doing anything
to sort of calm this down i mean i don't
understand how you can play under the
situation that you play under the way
people go
people are so focused on your game that
you're hearing all kinds of noises on
your back so we don't mind if it was
loud all the time people screaming
yelling and you had air horns going off
the entire time
it's fine like a football game but if
it's absolutely quiet and
all of a sudden you hear anything you
can hear pin drop it does distract you
right i mean i grew up on a military
base where you had jets and planes
flying over and you thought nothing of
it
right because you heard noise all the
time so we want noise and air horns all
the time from now on
that's what tiger woods is pleading for
now see what you've done this is not the
way to go
i have a few questions first of all i've
never is there trash
because trash talking is such a part of
sports now your good friend michael
jordan a master of i think
some trash talking is there trash
talking in in in professional golf
not like there used to be um there used
to be without a doubt without a doubt
guys like i remember being in the
master's dinner and talking to sam snead
and how sam used to always
talk trash coming down a stretch and he
would try and play games with you but i
thought was cool
right you know golf has changed um you
know we really don't do that anymore
which is you just kind of say it under
your breath
is that what you're going to use to hit
because
right i think you're just muttering a
lot like popeye yeah it's not the same
you i i believe you know we did a lot of
research for this segment for the first
time i actually researched a segment uh
so i wouldn't just be pissing at you
like a cat
but um you you there are very very
rarely is there a photograph of you
uh you know in your private life uh
you're you you play
it's good it is good it is good how do
you achieve that though i thought this
guy must have a bat cave or
a you're like a superhero you perform
these amazing feats and then you
disappear and i thought he must
he's like superman you have an an an
alter ego or you're uh
i think it's one of the one of the great
things that has happened is that
a lot of people just respect my space
and they respect what i do on a golf
course and my private life they respect
that because
everyone wants to have their quiet time
with their family and friends right and
i think what's been great is that
a lot of the fans and a lot of the media
have respected that that
part of my life you know what i think is
very very nice of them to do that
your your story is so well known and
everyone knows that that uh
you were interested and and excellent at
golf at a very early age with the age of
five
you could look at someone's grip or
their swing
and you could analyze it and break down
what was wrong with it and i was
thinking about that today and i thought
how annoying that must have been for
people to hear this from a five-year-old
did you make a lot of enemies back then
i probably did i probably
probably should have said some things
that i said like the kind of like what
are you doing there mister
what do you want cause that's not you're
gonna get your hip into it more who is
this
five he's right uh
uh you're good friends with charles
barkley yeah who
likes to play golf you play golf often
with charles barkley
i do okay this is a deposition i'm
taking forever
and your name is tiger woods is it not
uh wow
i'm bringing this up for a reason i was
looking and a lot of people have
commented on charles barkley's golf
swing and we got footage of it today and
i thought can i show this to you and you
analyze it for us
it might hurt their eyes take a look at
this and tell us what the hell is going
on here
sir charles
[Music]
what is he doing
first of all well if you if you look at
that you said he's got a speech
impediment
yeah there's something wrong happening
it also looks physically impossible he
stops his swing
two thirds of the way through he starts
it again and starts it again i tell you
what that's why he's one of the greatest
athletes of all time right yeah yeah
because i was looking at that that
shouldn't work that shouldn't go
anywhere and
it doesn't
i can't wait till the phone call i get
from him because of this yeah
we're on very late he might miss it uh
um do you ever this is a stupid question
but do you ever play mini golf
actually i have yes you have put me golf
and do you get as
intense when you play mini golf you sang
the windmill the speed is not
it's it's not always cool when a
five-year-old is able to do better
right right that's not cool right so you
actually do get out there early and like
look at the way
the dragon's mouth is opening
like you're studying the mini golf
course
it's not quite that bad it's not that
bad no it's probably pretty bad okay
uh let's talk about the video game um
this is the tiger woods pga tour
it looks like it's selling already uh
and the cool thing about this video game
is that uh you can create your own
players you can make them look
like you or uh
why did you gloss over that so quickly
but what you really want to do or you
can make them look like a stud
wow wow
wow that was in the rough that one uh
well actually to prove your point and
this is uh uh ea sports the people that
make this video game actually sent over
they made
a a portion of the video game that's
supposed to look like me
and how i would do if i shot uh
took a shot what my swing would look
like i guess and how i would do and they
sent this over today and i
i we haven't seen this yet but let's
take a look at this right now tell me if
you think this is accurate
[Applause]
um
that's what the pinwheel has
wow thanks a lot for the uh the bad
shorts the geeky glasses and the
pinwheel hat
he pulled it off well not a terrible
terrible shot
now you can also there i would imagine
so many golf games where you can play
yourself
because everybody wants to play tiger
woods when they play a video game and
they're playing golf
have you ever played yourself and if so
have you gotten incredibly competitive
with tiger woods usually my
my buddies usually play as me and i
usually have to pick someone else
right but that must be very strange you
should try it sometime where you just
are playing yourself
i i can't do it it just feels too weird
might be kind of kinky
let's move on that's not weird uh
tiger woods pga tour 2005 is in stores
uh right now and uh this has really been
a thrill for us thank you so much